OVER TO YOU, PETE.
PETE: ALL RIGHT, CALIFORNIA IS
ONE STEP CLOSER TO SEEING THEIR
GOVERNOR REMOVED FROM OFFICE, AS
A PETITION RECALL GAVIN NEWSOM
IS THAT 1.9 MILLION SIGNATURES
TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE DEADLINE
OUR NEXT GUEST IS A RESTAURANTS
AND DISTILLERY OWNER IN THE
STATE, SAYS THE RECALL
MOVEMENT BECAME HIS BUSINESS
AFTER LOCKDOWNS THREATENED HIS
LIVELIHOOD, CAL WEISS SPIRITS
COMPANY OWNER AND DISTILLER
AARON BERG JOINS US THANKS FOR
BEING WITH US THIS IS A BIG
MILESTONE, 1.9 HITTING THE
THRESHOLD, ARE YOU HOPEFUL
YOU’LL GET THERE, AND THAT GAVIN
NEWSOM WILL BE RECALLED?
>> I FEEL INCREDIBLY HOPEFUL TO
SEE THOSE NUMBERS.
I MEAN, I HAD SIGNATURES IN MY
BUSINESS RIGHT NOW THAT HAVEN’T
BEEN COLLECTED YET, I ASSUME A
LOT OF OTHER BUSINESSES HAVE
SIGNATURES TOO, AND I THINK
VOTES ARE PAST 2 MILLION, NO
PROBLEM.
PETE: WHEN CUSTOMERS WALK IN AND
YOU GIVE THEM AN OPTION TO SIGN
THE PETITION, WHAT’S THE
PERCENTAGE RATE WHEN THEY
SAY OH, YEAH, I’LL SIGN THAT.
>> YEAH, AT THIS POINT, MOST
PEOPLE WHO COME IN HAVE ALREADY
SIGNED IT, BUT ALMOST EVERYONE
WHO HASN’T ALREADY SIGNED IT
DOES, BECAUSE IT’S VERY EASY FOR
THEM TO CONNECT THE DOTS AND
REALIZE THAT I JUST TRIED TO
COME INTO MY FAVORITE BAR TO
TASTE SOME DELICIOUS SPIRITS OR
HAVE A MEAL AND I CAN’T DO THAT
RIGHT NOW, AND THERE’S ONE MAN
WHOSE IN THE WAY OF ME BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT IN A RESPONSIBLE
WAY AND IT’S VERY EASY FOR THEM
TO MAKE THE CONCLUSION OF I HAVE
TO SIGN THIS PETITION TO LET
THAT HAPPEN AGAIN.
PETE: SURE, NOW BUT AARON, I
BELIEVE GAVIN NEWSOM HAS OPENED
CALIFORNIA UP A LITTLE BIT,
RIGHT?
YOU’VE NOW BEEN OPEN FOR A
COUPLE THREE DAYS, AM I RIGHT?
AND ARE YOU GOING TO TAKE BACK
YOUR RECALL AND SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CRUMBS, MR. GOVERNOR?
>> NO, NOT AT THIS POINT.
WE ARE JUST ABLE TO OPEN UP
THREE DAYS AGO INDOORS, ONE OF
THE FEW COUNTIES IN THE STATE
THAT CAN AND EVEN THEN, WE’RE
ONLY AT 25% CAPACITY, AND I’M
NOT HOLDING MY BREATH BECAUSE
WE’VE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
I’VE KIND OF LOST COUNT BUT I
THINK WE’RE AT ABOUT SEVEN TIMES
I’VE HAD TO OPEN AND CLOSE MY
BUSINESS IN THE PAST YEAR, SO
I’M KIND OF HAPPY BUT I’M NOT, I
HAVEN’T LET A SIGH OF RELIEF
COME OUT YET.
PETE: AARON, IF IT HAD BEEN UP
TO YOUR LOCAL OFFICIALS, AND
THERE HADN’T BEEN A STATEWIDE
MANDATE ON THINGS WOULD YOU HAVE
BEEN OPEN A LOT SOONER
INDIFFERENT WAYS?
>> ABSOLUTELY OUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN AWESOME.
THEY’VE BEEN TRYING TO REACH OUT
TO THE STATE AND WORKING WITH
THE STATE AND LET US OPEN,
BECAUSE OUR HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN
RELATIVELY EMPTY HERE, AND
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN VERY
RESPONSIBLE HERE, AND THE COVID
HAS NOT BEEN WIDESPREAD AND THEY
WANT OUR BUSINESSES TO BE OPEN,
AND ALL WE HAVE GOT IN RESPONSE
IS SILENCE, NEWSOM HAS IGNORED
OUR PLEAS AND HE LITERALLY
BACKED A WILD ANIMAL INTO A
CORNER AND NOW WE HAVE NO OTHER
OPTION BUT TO LASH OUT IN A WAY
THAT’S RECALLING HIM.
PETE: HE’S IGNORED YOUR PLEAS
BUT HE CANNOT IGNORE THIS
PETITION.
AARON BERGH, GOOD ON YOU FOR
SPEAKING OUT FOR A LOT OF
BUSINESS OWNERS SQUASHED BY